THANK YOU.
♪ THROUGH THE
POURING RAIN... ♪♪
OKAY WENDY...
I TOLD THE AGENCY
TO SEND ANYBODY OVER,
REGARDLESS OF EXPERIENCE,
BECAUSE WE'RE
DESPERATE FOR HELP...
I JUST HAD ANOTHER KID
QUIT ON ME TODAY.
IT'S NICE TO HAVE AN ADULT
APPLYING FOR A CHANGE.
THANKS.
I'M CHANGING CAREERS
AND IT'S...
DIFFICULT TO GET
INTO A NEW FIELD.
OH, WHAT WAS
YOUR LAST JOB ?
I WAS KIND OF A WHORE.
AREN'T WE ALL
IN A WAY, HUH ?
I GUESS SO.
OKAY WENDY,
LET'S SEE EXACTLY
HOW YOU SOLD YOURSELF...
OKAY, IT SAYS HERE
THAT YOU WERE A DANCER,
WERE THESE
NATIONAL TOURS ?
NO, THEY WERE
STRIP CLUBS.
I PUT DOWN DANCING
BECAUSE I THOUGHT
IT SOUNDED BETTER.
OKAY, LET'S FORGET
ABOUT JOB EXPERIENCE,
I DON'T THINK
ANY OF IT'S GONNA APPLY.
OKAY, SPECIAL SKILLS:
"EATING WHILE DRIVING".
EXPLAIN THAT.
YOU KNOW HOW IT'S GOOD TO KILL
TWO BIRDS WITH TWO STONES ?
WELL--
CAN I SMOKE IN HERE ?
NO.
ANYWAY, IF I'M HUNGRY
AND I GOTTA DO
A LOT OF ERRANDS
I GET IN MY CAR, I GO
THROUGH THE DRIVE-THRU
AND THEN EAT WHILE
I DO MY ERRANDS.
Y'KNOW, LIKE IF I GOTTA
PICK UP A GIRL WHO DOESN'T
HAVE A CAR
OR I GOTTA SCORE
SOME SUPERCOOL
OR I GOTTA BUY
A BOX OF CONDOMS IN BULK--
OKAY WENDY, SPECIAL SKILLS
DON'T APPLY EITHER.
YOU HAVE A SECTION
ON YOUR RESUME ENTITLED
"MY DO's AND DON'Ts".
I'VE NEVER
SEEN THAT BEFORE.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
OKAY, WHAT DOES
THIS MEAN ?
I WON'T "S" THE "D"
AND YOU CAN'T "C" ON MY "F".
"I WON'T
SUCK YOUR DICK,
YOU CAN'T
COME ON MY FACE."
I PUT IT IN INITIALS
'CAUSE I THOUGHT
IT SOUNDED BETTER.
I WOULDN'T PUT THAT
ON MY RESUME.
WELL, THAT'S
MY OLD RESUME.
WHAT DOES
"D.P." STAND FOR ?
DOUBLE PENETRATION.
"T.P." ?
TRIPLE PENETRATION.
"FA/P/LM" ?
FARM ANIMALS / PETS /
LUNCH MEAT.
"L" INSIDE A "C" ?
I WON'T LAY
INSIDE A COFFIN.
"F" A "T" ?
I WON'T
FIST A TURKEY.
"DHD" ON A "HC" ?
I WILL NOT SUCK A
DOUBLE-HEADED DILDO
ON A HOVERCRAFT.
THAT'S INSANE !
I KNOW, THAT'S WHY
I WON'T DO IT !
"SECRET SANTA" IS THAT
WHAT I HOPE IT IS ?
YEAH, YEAH,
EVERY CHRISTMAS,
WE DO SECRET SANTA
AND I ALWAYS GIVE
THE BEST GIFTS.
OH, GREAT !
LIKE ONE YEAR
I GAVE THIS CHICK
THE HAND OF ADONIS
WITH THE MINTY GRAB BAG.
WHAT WAS THAT ?
IT'S A 12-INCH DILDO
WITH BALLS.
OKAY WENDY, I'M SORRY.
I'D LOVE TO GIVE YOU
YOUR FIRST BREAK,
BUT YOU'RE JUST NOT
QUALIFIED FOR THIS JOB.
OH, YOU ARE, HUH ?
I WOULDN'T ACT SO
SUPERIOR IF I WERE YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU, LIKE,
40-PLUS YEARS OLD ?
AND YOU SETTLED FOR
MANAGING A BUNCH OF TEENAGERS
IN A FRANCHISE
COFFEE SHOP.
IS THAT WHAT YOU
DREAMED OF...
WHEN YOU WERE
YOUNG... AND BEAUTIFUL ?
NO...
( sobbing )
OH CHRIST...
I WANTED TO BE
AN ASTRONAUT.
HEY...
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE
TO BE WHAT WE WANT TO BE.
♪ THE WHORE
AND THE MANAGER ♪
♪ BOTH TRYIN' TO
MEND THEIR WAYS ♪
♪ OHH, HE WANTS TO
LIVE ON THE MOON ♪
♪ SHE JUST WANTS
TO WORK DAYS ♪
♪ SHE CAME UP
FROM POVERTY ♪
♪ AND HE CAME UP
FROM SENSIBLE STUFF ♪
♪ OHHH, THE WHORE
DREAMS OF LIVING CLEAN ♪
♪ HE DREAMS OF
LIVING HIS ROUGH ♪
♪ WHEN GOD
MADE US ALL ♪
♪ HE HAD A DREAM ♪
♪ WE WOULD LIVE
OUR OWN WAY... ♪
♪ AND THE WHORE
AND THE MANAGER ♪
♪ THEY'LL GET THERE TOO ♪
♪ BUT THERE'S A PRICE
THEY'LL HAVE TO PAY... ♪
♪ WE ALL PRAY, PRAYYYY ♪
♪ WE ALL PRAY,
PRAYYYY ♪
♪ FOR WHAT
WE HAVE TODAY ♪
YOU'VE GIVEN ME STRENGTH
TO FOLLOW MY DREAMS.
I'M GOING TO QUIT THIS PLACE
AND JOIN THE SPACE PROGRAM.
GOOD FOR YOU.
AND I'M GOING TO
THROW YOU A WILD PARTY,
'CAUSE I NEVER HAD AN
ASTRONAUT FRIEND BEFORE.
♪ WHAT WE HAVE...
TODAY ♪